demander un référendum sur ce projet de
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite
sonne aujourd'hui comme une évidence
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
de la majorité présidentielle et
sénatoriale aujourd'hui main dans la
main je vous le redis le rejet de cette
mesure provocatrice est massif dans ce
pays c'est une provocation de répondre
par l'obligation de travailler plus
longtemps à la détresse à l'angoisse de
la population frappée par la crise du
covid victime d'une précarité croissante
dans le travail et dans la vie
quotidienne et qui subit une inflation à
deux chiffres sur les produits
alimentaires et de première nécessité
c'est une provocation à les garder femme
déjà victimes de discrimination en
matière salariale d'évolution de
carrière plutôt que l'égalité vous
ajoutez de la maltraitance en
rallongeant soit leur travail soit leur
période de chômage car vous savez bien
qu'en reculant l'âge de la retraite
c'est le chômage des seniors que vous
prolongez le message que vous envoyez
aux femmes et des plus
vous leur dites qu'elles vont travailler
plus longtemps mais que l'écart entre
leurs pensions et celles des hommes qui
s'élèvent faut-il leur rappeler à 40%,
va être moindre mais ce que veulent les
femmes ce n'est pas un écart cosmétique
c'est l'égalité
depuis 2017 le président Macron a fait
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes une grande cause nationale alors
mettez on adéquation ces paroles et ses
actes l'égalité salariale et l'égalité
d'accès à l'emploi des femmes
permettrait de résoudre le pseudo
déficit qui justifie votre réforme
inique avec les amis de mon groupe mais
aussi de toute la gauche sénatoriale
nous sommes scandalisés par les
propositions de Monsieur Retailleau
s'appuyant sur une idéologie
familialiste nationaliste d'une époque
que je n'oser non monsieur Retailleau
les femmes ne peuvent avoir pour seule
solution afin d'éviter de travailler
jusqu'à un âge indéterminé que de faire
plus d'enfants nous vous demandons de
retirer cette proposition par dignité
c'est une provocation à l'égard de la
jeunesse durement éprouvée par le covid
par un monde un certain des guerres dans
de nombreux pays la menace d'une
troisième guerre mondiale une jeunesse
conf cette inquiétant réchauffement
climatique soumise à un parcours
scolaire et universitaire de plus en
plus sélectif dans des conditions de
plus en plus difficiles que
proposez-vous à la jeunesse un service
national universel autoritaire une forme
d'embryonnement insupportable pour
celles et ceux qui ont soif de liberté
et une carrière qui ne se terminera
qu'avec la vieillesse car quelle
étudiant pourra espérer une retraite
avant 70 ans c'est une provocation pour
les travailleuses et les travailleurs y
compris celles et ceux qui exercent des
métiers pénibles ou une carrière longue
ou maltraitez aujourd'hui celles et ceux
que vous couvriez hypocritement de
louange ses premières et premiers de
corvées durant la crise du covid oui la
colère est grande et elle s'amplifie la
mobilisation à compter du 7 mars annonce
massive c'est une très bonne nouvelle et
hier dans l'hémicycle nous avons pu
vivre cette opposition entre deux
projets de société aux antipodes dans un
clivage droite-gauche enfin assumé y
compris au bord du gouvernement monsieur
Macron et son gouvernement veut passer
au forceps en utilisant cette procédure
de l'article 47 1 si décrié depuis sa
mise en œuvre pour l'examen de cette
réforme des retraites et qui relève du
détournement de procédures nous l'avons
infirmé hier vous violez la Constitution
pour imposer cette réforme vous
contraignez le Parlement vous tentez de
le soumettre et nous sommes choqués par
cette majorité sénatoriale qui avait
affiché son statut de contre-pouvoir de
lieu de résistance à l'autoritarisme de
Monsieur Macron à se mépris du Parlement
et qui aujourd'hui l'accompagne avec
complaisance et oui mes chers collègues
vous accompagnez le président de la
République dans cette mise au pas du
Parlement pire cet engirement du
Parlement puisqu'intex non soumis au
vote de l'Assemblée nationale et
peut-être même non soumis au vote des
deux chambres si le gouvernement n'ouvre
pas plus de jours de débat un débat et
une adoption CMP dominée par des
parlementaires LR pourtant en perte
d'influence dans l'opinion publique
c'est un quelque force institutionnelle
il faut donner au peuple les moyens d'y
résister lui donner les moyens c'est lui
donner la parole c'est soumettre ce
texte au référendum qui ici peut oser
dire alors que plus de 90% des actifs
rejettent le texte restons nous au
Sénats
fondamental dans un temps contraint et
barons la route à l'expression populaire
tout vote contre cette motion
référendaire est un acte grave contre la
démocratie ça elles et ceux qui
s'interont dans ce déni de démocratie
porteront la responsabilité de la mise à
l'arrêt du pays et d'une légitime
révolte avec le groupe CRCE je vous
appelle donc solennellement à voter
cette notion référendaire sans hésiter
[Musique]